bescheuert dass man jetzt so alte Themen
wieder hoch holt vor allem jetzt wo es
um irgendwas geht mir auch Sachen größer
gezogen als sie sind ist jung man macht
viele
[Musik]
dazu irgendwas mitbekommen mit dem mit
dem einwanger habt ihr diese dieses
Flugblatt gesehen maximal lesen einfach
was denken Sie jetzt über diese diese
Fragen und Antworten finden Sie das
glaubwürdig
[Musik]
sind keine Fehler das ist das ist
Provokation sowas
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unterwegs nach Niederbayern unser Ziel
Rottenburg an der Laaber Heimat von
Hubert albern
rund
8.500 Einwohner leben hier bei den
letzten Landtagswahlen stimmte fast die
Hälfte für Ellwanger Freie Wähler
wir machen uns auf den Weg ohne
Verabredungen ohne großes Kamerateam
wollen herausfinden was denken die
Menschen hier über Hubert Aiwanger die
flugblattaffäre und seinen Umgang mit
den Vorwürfen
und das ist richtig geschmutzkampagnen
oder sowas
das ist ja noch mal eine ganz andere
Nummer ich glaube gar nicht
weil ich bin ja viele im Internet
die Rentnerin verdient sich als
grabpflegerin was dazu auch auf dem
Friedhof erzählt sie uns ist Aiwanger
Gesprächsthema
sein Bruder dass das richtige
Schweinerei ist
was da los ist
sie erklärt uns den Weg zu aiwangers
Bruder Helmut er hat sich als Verfasser
des Flugplatz bekannt betreibt dem Ort
einen Waffenladen
alles dunkel keiner da wir versuchen ihn
zu erreichen
[Musik]
er sei weggefahren komme so schnell
nicht wieder meint die Nachbarin von
nebenan
Susanne gorfer ist Verkäuferin im
Einzelhandel seit der flugblattaffäre
sein Rottenburg ordentlich was los sagt
sie
gut sagen wir mal und und und er
vertritt auch einiges und aber dass sie
jetzt dann auch ein Bruder losgehen und
dann mit diesen Flugblättern und alles
also das ist ja Jahre her das war ja in
der Schule ich meine wir haben alle
irgendwo was im hinter Ding sitzen und
da muss es jetzt nicht so rauskommen
finde ich haben sie das Flugblatt
gesehen ich habe das Flugblatt leider
nicht gesehen
[Musik]
wie soll ich mich jetzt ausdrücken
nicht schön sagen wir mal so das andere
Wort möchte ich nicht also das ist nicht
schön was hier drin steht das ist
wirklich etwas
was früher gewesen ist was nicht so
schön war was man nicht wieder haben
möchten und deswegen sage ich dieses
Flugblatt hätte gar nicht erscheinen
dürfen ja das was für Sie das immer so
gelesen zu haben ja das ändert viel und
dieses Flugblatt ist ist eine Frechheit
verbotenlose Frechheit nicht nur das
antisemitische Flugblatt das während der
Schulzeit bei Hubert ailwanger gefunden
wurde und über das die Süddeutsche
Zeitung berichtet hat auch sein Umgang
mit den Vorwürfen haben wenige Wochen
vor den Landtagswahlen in Bayern Fragen
aufgeworfen
wir werden 25 Fragen die wir
zusammenstellen
es ist einfach wichtig auch mit solch
einer Beantwortung rein in den Tisch zu
machen Klarheit für alle zu schaffen
meine aufrichtige Entschuldigung gilt so
vor dass tollen Opfern das in Österreich
und allen Beteiligten und der wertvollen
Erinnerungsarbeit
[Applaus]
hier wurde von langer Hand geplant in
Aiblinger fertig zu machen ich hatte das
Gefühl dass auch sein
eine Heu und auch seine seine
Distanzierung von dem Flugblatt und dem
Inhalt des Flugplatz des
zugegebenermaßen pickelhaft widerlich
und reiner nazischaugen war es war für
mich glaubhaft am Ende
Schlussstrich Mentalität jetzt die wir
eigentlich beobachten können also
diese Debatte so schnell wie möglich zu
beenden und weitermachen als wäre nie
etwas passiert das ist etwas was junge
Jüdinnen und Juden in diesem Land nicht
so einfach tun können
aiwangers Antworten auf Söders 25 Fragen
zeigen wir so seine gäufer was sagt sie
zu seinem Umgang mit den Vorwürfen
ganz ehrlich sagen
ich finde es nicht glaubwürdig was er
geantwortet hat
weil er er sagt ja er hat er hat es
gewusst oder er kann sich nicht mehr
dran erinnern ob er ob er mit dabei war
aber das sind alles so fragen
meine friert sich praktisch er will sich
raus meine früheren aus der ganzen Sache
und er soll aber zu dem Fehlern stehen
ändert das was jetzt an ihrer Sicht auf
Aiwanger ob ich jetzt noch ein Kreuzchen
mache weiß ich nicht die meisten mit
denen wir hier sprechen sehen das anders
stehen hinter Aiwanger Medien berichten
neben dem Flugblatt auch unter anderem
von hitlergrüßen im Klassenzimmer bei
Wanger dementiert das nicht viele
verfolgen die flugblätterfähre erst gar
nicht vertrauen Politik und Medien immer
weniger erzählen sie uns
machen sehr wenig für die Menschen hast
du irgendwas mitbekommen mit dem mit dem
ivaner so jetzt direkt nicht leider weil
Nachrichten hört leider nicht sehr oft
warum liest du nicht so viel Nachrichten
weil die meisten Nachrichten alle
hauptsächlich finde ich persönlich sehr
viel manipuliert sind also man kann
nicht mehr glauben was wahr ist oder was
nicht wahr ist
bei ihnen ist Hubert Aiwanger gerade
Thema als wir sie ansprechen fast jeden
Tag treffen sie sich nach Feierabend
hier auf dem Parkplatz
das zweite war was habt ihr von allem
wenn er von von dem für ein Eindruck
bislang gehabt
ja ich kenne persönlich durch
Nachbarschaft
er ist
aufgeschlossener Mensch ganz klar also
ich kann nichts schlecht gegen den
und das ganze mit der Affäre jetzt damit
vor 35 Jahren das ist für mich
irrelevant und irgendwo
charakterschwach vor demjenigen dem das
jetzt einfach nur 35 gehört das
was man das jetzt so aufputzen muss ich
finde das sollte jetzt überhaupt nicht
mehr darüber gesprochen werden
im Endeffekt zählt ja Wasser im hier und
jetzt sagt
würde ihr frei wer da wählen oder
was ich wählen soll
zeigen wir das Flugblatt wozu sich
aiwangers Bruder bekannt hat und die
Antworten von Hubert Aiwanger auf die
Vorwürfe
ich bin immer noch der Meinung dass man
als junger Mensch unüberlegte Dinge tut
und das ändert jetzt nicht die Sache
also ich finde dass es im Prinzip immer
noch um dieselbe Situation geht man
macht Dinge worüber man vielleicht in
jungen Jahren jetzt nicht unbedingt
nachdenkt und es gehört halt einfach zu
dem ganzen dazu und deswegen ändert sich
das ändert sich da für mich nichts was
ging da dir durch den Kopf wenn du das
Blatt gelesen hast schon heftig wie es
formuliert worden ist
die flugblattaffäre wer der vor der
Landtagswahl in Bayern größer gemacht
als sie sei finden Sie
zum Beispiel eine gewisse
whatsapp-gruppen wo
ältere Leute dabei sind von gewissen
Vereinen oder so
dort zum Beispiel jemand ist eine
geschickt und so ungefähr ja wir können
jetzt wieder raus
und da war dann halt die Diskussion
drunter so ja
35 kg
hier wo Hubert Aiwanger aufgewachsen ist
und auch einmal jung war halten sie
weiter zu ihm tagelang hat der Fall
Aiwanger für Aufsehen gesorgt je näher
man seine Heimat kommt desto weiter
scheint hier Empörung entfernt